Hello,
freak bitches.
That stink.
Yeah,
the bathroom smells so bad.
The bathroom smells so bad from pollution.
I think just from the polluted water,
just polluted water makes it smell man.
And also they don't.
They don't want,
you can't even say it died.
Thinking about it,
they have a lot of toilets.
Was just no toilet.
It's just,
it's just a porcelain hole.
You have to.
Squat is a squat.
Supposedly.
It's better for your bowels.
Supposedly I was in the Forbidden City.
I was walking around there with the emperor's palace.
Yeah.
And I got bad diarrhea.
It was bad.
Like sweating,
like I gotTa Fuck Fuck.
And then there's a picture toilet and you go in there and you fucking run and
smells.
As soon as you cross the threshold of the smells and you open up the first toy,
the stall door and your mind can't even register it first.
Like,
this must be under construction because there's no toilet here.
So that's the only explanation.
And then you go to the next one and you're like,
what?
Oh,
zero papers.
No,
there's no paper.
Well,
first I just said,
I'm not doing this.
I'm not.
I walked away.
Oh my God.
I was like,
I took like two steps out of the bathroom,
and I was like,
oh yeah,
diarrhea,
what do you mean I'm not doing it?
Of course I'm doing it.
So you went back in and wash your butt.
You have to do.
So this guy who owned the bar,
the club was in Shanghai,
gave me this,
these,
this tissue packet,
and he goes,
you'll need it.
I thought it was for pollution,
and he goes,
you'll need this.
And I just had.
Yeah.
And then it was like,
oh yeah,
you got to pull your pants all the way down.
Squat over it,
but also try to shit into your pants.
You can't go over the balls of your feet.
Oh No,
there's probably a better way.
What do you do with explosive diarrhea though?
It seems like you're going to miss lasted into that hole.
You're,
you're,
you're like half a foot over the hole.
Is that good for your quads?
It's good for your core.
That definitely.
I would feel like that would really work your core a lot and there's no air
conditioning.
It's so hot that would work here.
Resolve.
Yeah.
That's why the is a thing.
Maybe it's not the low sugar diet shit.
You hate your ankles.
So because I'm going to have explosive diarrhea feels was like.
I'm just going to hit my picture.
This picture,
this I'm down,
I'm squatting right now.
So like your,
your ass is right over the whole filling the hole essentially.
Feet.
If you're moved to far enough away,
what do you do if you have bad knees,
you do after that.
But I sit like that all the time.
That's how it usually just squat,
eat all the time.
I do that sometimes.
It's like that.
Yeah,
sure.
Once in a while back,
it's just
in one of those toilets,
somebody dropped their brand new phone in the toilet and so the husband went to
go in there and grab it passed down because of the fumes.
And the woman tried to grab
the guy out.
Two people died.
Three injured,
uh,
falling in,
stand by me with.
They're all barfing smelling
so good.
America,
Dick Cheney's,
right.
They had those.
They have those shutters on the train when it's moving around and stuff.
They have those shitters Dick Cheney's.
Right.
I opened up my tissue packets.
What?
What did he say?
Right.
We have the best.
It sounds like.
Can we do a douchebag definition possible?
When you say Douche bag there,
I'm curious as to what specifically just dumb assholes,
assholes.
Like you ever go to Kim Kardashians instagram page.
None of them.
A little wheezes.
Go there and just read some of the comments about children.
Anything.
Anything that's just fucking.
Hey,
I'm sure it's.
I'm sure it's there.
It's diluted.
Youtube.
It's because it's you're,
you're.
You're commenting on a photo or a video instead of like a twitter where you're
just talking about words for it.
I honestly think anything worth anything should be comments,
deleted,
comments,
disabled,
because the problem is they very rarely,
it's.
It's rare that you.
It generates a really fascinating conversation in the comments.
It's super common that it just country shitheads.
It depends on the subject matter.
Like in,
in my case,
sometimes I do get relevant discussion in the comments,
a tech discussion,
like did it pretty respectful,
but you do get this weird fanboys and stuff that gets a militant surprisingly is
like a more way.
I don't know.
I have this theory like,
you know,
when you go to a coffee shop and you look around you at starbucks,
everyone has their phones on the table.
You notice that like,
yeah,
like it's in a public space,
it's like representative of you in some way.
And I have this feeling that this is for a lot of people,
this is a major investment,
you know,
outside of their car or whatever.
It's really close to you.
It's in your pocket all the time.
And so I think people are really concerned with making the wrong decision.
You know,
they're really concerned that their thing is not the best.
And so in my case what will happen is I'll put up a video within,
you know,
they haven't even had time to finish watching it and apple socs or android sucks
or whatever.
And really it's fear.
It's fear that you made the wrong decision and so it,
well,
like many places in life,
you get angry when you're afraid and so,
God forbid a new product comes out that obsoletes yours and you don't have the
money to replace it.
So you take this position of defending the other thing because that's easier
than justifying the cost of the new one.
So,
uh,
I've,
I've actually,
uh,
there were a couple of really cool articles on Fanboy ism that I was interviewed
for and you know,
we went,
we went deep into how,
you know,
how people sort of figured that out.
But uh,
there's definitely this undercurrent below the tech space,
the consumer product space where these are becoming more and more like fashion
symbols,
like,
like a,
you know,
rep representative of your,
maybe more so than this then as a tool,
you know,
less,
less of a hammer and more like a piece of jewelry,
like a watch or something.
Isn't it also that people just love being on teams,
whether it's team.
Oh,
Publican team shelly most,
most definitely.
And,
and I've done some rants on this in the past.
Like I feel the need to tell people like I'm a fan of technology when I was
coming up as a kid,
like if anybody brought me any of this stuff,
I would be super excited of course.
And I'm cool with saying that,
you know,
but uh,
but yeah,
there is,
there is definitely a team aspect where people,
they want to belong to something I say belong to team technology if that's what
you're into.
Because the truth is these devices and these platforms push one another that the
positive things that happened in android push ios to be better than the positive
things that happened in Ios push android to be better.
And the same thing goes for laptops,
desktops really anywhere.
There's innovation.
Having a little bit of competition is a positive thing.